vous devriez aller à amsterdam
j'ai une correspondance à londres votre
carte d'embarquement
vous appelez ça fait mal athis mons et
j'ai rien fait je comprends pas écouter
les couloirs qui fait de la menace ou de
quoi vous fassiez j'avais poussé fier
immédiatement je tiens un suspect je
vais arrêter là ma vérifié ses
antécédents siègent 24 deux hommes
bohème power6 vous avait il également
fait subir un contrôle on n'a pas le
temps de se servir avant votre départ et
vous l'avez monaco je le voulais pas
ratifié votre vol de retour et vous avez
dit vous feriez ce que vous aviez deux
femmes menacés père est un crack
je vous que vous fassiez leur chien sur
tom boën thiès 24e
maintenant ça suffit de suite vous
perdez un temps précieux en mars vous
être enlevée de vos fonctions
est ce que vous ne comprenez dont trois
minutes quelqu'un à bord de cet avion va
mourir est ce que vous me comprenez